hear people say to me why do you use the
word nationalism why can't you say use
patriotism George Orwell for example
argued for that and the problem is since
we are talking about semantics first
let's be clear about the idea rather
than the terms the idea is a world of
independent nations that's that's what
we're trying to describe and the reason
that I use nationalism is because that
is actually the traditional word for
that ideology and I'm not that
interested in altering my vocabulary
because of Hitler I don't want to learn
political Theory from Hitler the word
patriotism it's a perfectly fine word
but patriotism means my love of my
country but now we move into Political
Theory we're looking for a general
principle what term do we use to
describe the idea that the world should
consist is better off if it is governed
as a world of independent nations the
term patriotism doesn't come close to
capturing that and nationalism simply
does it